There are some different ways
of expressing multiplication
that we will use throughout this course.
They look different, but
they mean the same thing.
You may be familiar with
this notation where an x or
a cross in the middle
means multiplication.
We just use this notation where
a dot means multiplication.
Sometimes a star or
an asterisk will be used the same way.
Finally, we can express multiplication
by putting the numbers we want to
multiply into parentheses and
then placing them directly
next to each other.
These all mean the same thing,
that we're multiplying two by two.
Which of these does not mean
the same thing as the others?
Please select one.